دعت عائلته والزميل الراحله شيرين ابو
عاقله الى قداس نصف السنه في كنيسه اللقاء
بضحيه بيت حنينا شمال القدس المحتله
القداسه في وقت تتواصل فيه الجهود محليا
ودوليا لتحقيق العداله لشيرين حيث تواصلوا
شبكه الجزيره جهودها من اجل محاسبه الجنان
الان الى كنيسه اللقاء تنضم الينا من هناك
في بيت حنينا الشماليه القدس مراسله
الجزيره نجوان مرحبا بك ضعينا في
اجواء هذا القداس وابرز الحاضرين
[موسيقى]
نعم محمد القداس انتهى قبل قليل حاليا
العائله في هذه القاعه يصل الى هنا
الاقرباء والاصدقاء
للتعزيه وهذا القداس اقيم بعد مضي نحو نصف
عام على اغتيال الزميل لشيرين لراحته
نفسها شارك فيها العائله وايضا واصدقاء
والزملاء من مكتبنا في القدس و رام الله
يعني اقرباء للشهيده شيرين ابو عاقله
بطبيعه الحال هذه القضيه ما زالت تتفاعل
ربما
انصحاء القول فان معادله الوقت مع غياب
شيرين لا تعمل كما هو متوقع بشكل عام
بمعنى انها مع مضيء الوقت ما زالت العائله
ما زال الاصدقاء يشعرون وكان شيرين
اغتيلات هذا اليوم هي نفس المشاعر مشاعر
طب الحسره في القلب محمد ولكن مع ذلك
تتواصل الجهود همم ضمن مساعي محاوله تحقيق
عداله شيرين من خلال محاسبه ومسائله ايه
قاتليها اا هناك منظمات دوليه ما زالت
تسعى لتحقيق ذلك وبطبيعه الحال قناه
الجزيره وشبكه الجزيره بالاثاث تعمل من
اجل ذلك همم كانت نقابه الصحفيين
الفلسطينيين والاتحاد الصحفيين الدولي الى
جانب منظمات حقوقيه قد قدمت شكوى قبل فتره
وجيزه لمحكمه الجنايات الدوليه همم باسم
اغتيال شيرين ابو عاقل الى جانب عدد من
الصحفيين الفلسطينيين الا اخرين هذا
بالاضافه الى شكوى اخرى تقدمت بها السلطه
الفلسطينيه اا نتحدث عن 55
صحفيا فلسطينيا
استشهدوا برصاص الاحتلال منذ عام 2000 فقط
بعد اغتيال شيرين تم اغتيال ايضا صحفيه
اخرى من منطقه مدينه الخليل هي غفران
وراثنه همم وهذا ربما يثير قلق الصحفيين
الفلسطينيين من تزايد اعمال العنف
والانتهاكات بحقهم من قبل الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي لاسيما وانه لا توجد هناك
محاسبه او مساءله حتى عندما همم اعلن جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي عن انتهاء تحقيقاته
الداخليه في مقتل شيرين يعني المحب بشكل
واضح الى ان احد جنوده هو من قام بقتل
شيرين بطبيعه الحال الجنود الاسرائيليين
لا يقومون بتنفيذ مثل هذه الممارسات دون
توجيهات عليا ناسيه وان كافه التحقيقات
التي اجريت اظهرت بانه كان استهداف مباشر
للمنطقه التي كانت مكشوفه
بين الخوذه التي كانت تضعها شيرين و بين
الدرع الواقي وبالتالي لم ير- يتحمل
المسؤوليه وابقى الباب مشرعا وكان كان
هناك مسلحين اخرين في المنطقه رغم ان كل
التحقيقات التي اجريت محمد وكانت هناك
سلسله من التحقيقات لكبرى وسائل الاعلام
العالميه ومنظمات حقوقيه دوليه اخرى اظهرت
انه لم يكن هناك مسلحين وان النيران اطلقت
على شيرين من اتجاه جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي شكرا لك
نجوان اذن من كنيسه اللقاء في بيت حنينا
الشماليه القدس شكرا جزيلا لكن نجوى
السمري